لدينا أخبار عاجلة
لإبلاغك الآن عن مذيع cnn كريس كومو في
وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع تم تعليق كومو
من CNN بعد أن كشفت الوثائق أنه
متورط أكثر مما كان معروفًا في السابق
وتشكيل شقيقه الحاكم السابق
أندرو كومو دفاع cuomo كريس كومو
يجب أن نشير  تم الآن
إنهاء هنا في CNN ، هذه هي آخر
الأخبار العاجلة أه حول ما يحدث
هنا في CNN أريد أن أذهب إلى cnn's brian
stelter
آه بريان أه من الواضح أن
هذا خبر ضخم أه ليس فقط داخل CNN
ولكن بالنسبة لهذه الصناعة ماذا يمكنك أن تقول
نحن
نعم ، كريس كومو ، أحد أشهر
المذيعين في CNN ، أحد أشهر
الأسماء في الأخبار التليفزيونية انتهك
الأخلاق والمعايير الصحفية ليس مرة
أو مرتين ولكن عدة مرات وهذا في
النهاية
ما هو نتيجة أخبار جيم اليوم
كما ذكرت كومو للتو  أنهيت من
قبل سي إن إن بعد ظهر هذا اليوم وهنا
بيان من الإدارة يشرح
القرار القائل بأن كريس كومو قد تم
تعليقه في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع pendin
تقييم إضافي للمعلومات الجديدة
التي تم الكشف عنها حول مشاركته
في دفاع أخيه ، قمنا بتعيين
مكتب محاماة محترم لإجراء
المراجعة وقمنا بإنهائه ساري المفعول على
الفور
أثناء عملية المراجعة
، ظهرت معلومات إضافية إلى الضوء
على الرغم من الإنهاء.  سوف
يحقق في الأمر حسب الاقتضاء ، فهذه
مفاجأة كبيرة لكثير من الأشخاص ،
لم أكن أتوقع أن أكون معك هذا
المساء للحديث عن هذه الأخبار العاجلة ،
لكننا علمنا أن cuomo قد تم
تعليقه ليس فقط كما تعلم لمدة أسبوع
لا  من النوع الذي يمثل
تعليقًا وهميًا لتخفيف الضغط على CNN ،
كان هذا تعليقًا حقيقيًا تم وضعه على
مقاعد البدلاء إلى أجل غير مسمى أثناء قيام الإدارة
بإجراء مراجعة ما لم نكن نعرفه
حتى هذه الليلة ، وهو أن شركة محاماة خارجية
دخلت أيضًا و  أن مكتب المحاماة
قد استعرض آلاف الصفحات من
الرسائل النصية والشهادة المحلفة التي
تم إصدارها يوم الاثنين ، لذلك من
الواضح أن هناك شيئًا ما في تلك الرسائل  كومنتس أه
تبين أنه انتهاك خطير
للمعايير والممارسات أه بالطبع
كان معروفًا منذ أشهر أن كريس كومو
كان يساعد شقيقه في التحدث إلى
أخيه بينما كان شقيقه يحاول
التمسك بالوالي والدفاع عن
نفسه وسط التحرش الجنسي
المزاعم التي تعلمناها هذا الأسبوع في
تلك الرسائل النصية وفي تلك
الشهادة المحلفة أنه كان
يتصرف بشكل أساسي كموظف كان مثل
موظف غير مدفوع الأجر للمحافظ
وكان يفعل ذلك في نفس الوقت الذي كان
يعمل فيه في CNN الآن هناك  جزء واحد
من بيان جيم أننا لا نعرف
أي شيء عنه لمجرد أن نكون
شفافين تمامًا مع الجمهور يقول إن
هناك معلومات
إضافية ظهرت أيضًا في وقت ما هذا الأسبوع أه
لا نعرف ما الذي لدي  سئل
ليس هناك إجابات قادمة بشأن ما
يمكن أن يكون ما نعرفه هو أنه
تم إنهاء cuomo في وقت سابق اليوم آه نحن نعلم
في الماضي أنني تواصلت مع كريس
وطلبت منه تعليقات ولم أفعل
سمعنا رده لكننا نعلم في الماضي
أنه قال إنه دائمًا ما يضع الأسرة في المقام الأول ،
وقال إنه آسف لوضع
زملائه في CNN في موقف صعب
الآن لأن الموقف الصعب لن يكون
موجودًا لأن chris cuomo قد تم
إنهاؤه
[موسيقى]